what are the best things to do if they
have advanced liver disease because if
you had the ability to handle the worst
case scenario then you'd be in pretty
good shape because most people don't
have the end stage liver disease they
have some type of stage that's before
that as you may already know the liver
goes through stages it may start off in
an inflamed State and then go into the
fatty stage
and then serotic stage which are scar
tissue or you can start with a fatty
liver which then produces more
inflammation and then turns into
cirrhosis now typically
on average it takes like 10 years to go
from a fatty liver all the way into
cirrhosis right and during that process
many times
it's silent you Just One Day end up with
this serious problem that gave you no
clues now you may have some you know
fatigue weakness things like that but
you may not identify or connect the dots
and I'm including in that category all
the people with a fatty liver I mean
just think about if you take a look at
your your toes right now and you're
standing up and you can't see your toes
because your belly is in the way we know
your liver is fatty because the fat
around the organs in the abdominal area
is a spill-off from the liver being too
fatty I mean just think about how many
people actually have belly fat I mean
it's very very high so this video
definitely includes anyone with belly
fat as well here's the thing
um the liver is very robust it's one of
the only organs that can completely
regenerate but it does take time it
could take three years or longer if you
have too much scar tissue in the liver
because you have cirrhosis there is a
point of no return you have to get on
the waiting list for a New River and
unfortunately it's a very long list that
being said there's not a lot of studies
in this area
I want to talk about what I would do if
I had Advanced cirrhosis of the liver
and I was in the transplant list what
would I do okay that's what I'm going to
talk about because that's like the worst
case scenario you know the doctor says
it's permanent there's no chance of
reversing this well let's talk about it
because there's actually six things that
I want to discuss the first thing that I
would do is get my body into a state of
autophagy what is autophagy it's the
condition where your body is recycling
damaged proteins in the cells so it's a
bit of recycling things you don't need
or damaged parts of your body including
the liver and then making new proteins
as well but that's only the tip of the
iceberg there's a lot more that
autophagy does for your body like for
example cancer originates in the
mitochondria you also have all the scar
tissue or fibrosis in the liver where
autophagy can help clean some of that up
autophagy also can help get rid of
intracellular pathogen it's like viruses
and bacteria and yeast so it can clean
those up as well I mean you've heard of
the condition hepatitis right well that
involves a virus so again autophagy is
very very important in helping your
liver all right so what can trigger
autophagy the biggest thing is fasting
okay regular intermittent fasting where
you're fasting on a daily basis you're
going for like 18 hours and you're
eating within a six hour window and then
especially periodic prolonged fasting so
once a week you fast for 48 hours once a
month maybe you fast for a week why is
that so important because you can really
create a significant Dent into this
problem by doing prolonged fasting if
you have cirrhosis and scar tissue and
apparently you can even get autophagy
while you're fasting within four hours
because the liver is used to this action
of replacing a lot of cells on a regular
basis so we have fasting okay
intermittent and prolong we also have
exercise exercise can stimulate
autophagy right you have sleep can
activate autophagy ketones can activate
autophagy right that's getting on a low
carb diet that's eliminating snacking
and then we also have other types of
therapy like cold therapy taking cold
shower Asana or infrared therapy coffee
has a certain polyphenol that can help
with autophagy of course
it's not going to be significant it's
not going to compare to autophagy so
just by drinking a pot of coffee a day
is not going to help you also extra
virgin olive oil can help to a certain
degree with autophagy and also consuming
more cruciferous vegetables all right
number two which is actually part of one
but it's specifically fasting okay
fasting helps with autophagy but it does
other things for your liver that I want
to discuss number one it actually
significantly lowers inflammation if you
can get rid of the inflammation you
could definitely stop this whole process
from getting worse fasting also
significantly increases your antioxidant
networks without actually taking
antioxidants and the other cool thing
that fasting will do it will decrease
liver enzymes so now let's talk about
number three
what is tadka tadka is a type of bile
salt it's also been used in Chinese
medicine for over 3000 years so it's
been around for a very long time but if
you actually do research on tatka in
relationship to liver function uh you'll
be blown away
first of all it helps thin the bile
because one of the underlying causes of
a liver problem is there's some type of
blockage within the bile ducts and the
bile can actually act as a detergent and
irritate and even Scar the liver Tut cut
also directly decreases fibrosis tadka
directly rehabs the hepatocyte the liver
cell tadka also protects the liver cell
against certain things like oxidation
and when you take tadka I'm not going to
get into necessarily Brands but you want
to take two on an empty stomach in the
morning and two in the afternoon on an
empty stomach because if you take it
with food it tends to act on the food as
a bile salt and not on your liver what's
the next thing well you want to induce
or trigger phase one phase two
detoxification this phenomena or enzyme
process occurs in your liver where
you're turning poisons into harmless
particles okay so it's converting these
fat soluble chemicals into harmless
water-soluble chemicals that get
released through the bile ducts in other
ways and so when the liver gets damaged
you you don't have this process working
at Full Throttle and that can back
things up especially poison since the
liver is constantly breaking down
poisons and protecting you like in
Sulfur Rich vegetables like in
cruciferous broccoli brussels sprouts
cabbage arugula radish things like that
green tea is another trigger for phase
one phase two detoxification and
straight sulforaphane which is the
phytonutrient in broccoli Sprouts so if
you add broccoli Sprouts to your salad
you can greatly help your liver and the
next one on the list is milk thistle so
as you can see we're really hitting this
problem over the head with a
sledgehammer because these are all all
the most potent things to help your
liver okay milk thistle is a very
interesting herb it's this weed that you
can consume the seeds in fact a lot of
people you have it in their backyard so
you can grab some and grind the seeds
and and put it on your salad and it
protects the liver against poisons even
poisonous snakes even poisonous
mushrooms in fact if you're also on
medication on a regular basis or you
know someone who's on medication have
them start taking milk thistle just to
reduce some of the side effects but it
basically gives you properties to
protect the liver it also prevents
fibrosis it decreases inflammation it
helps neutralize toxins it helps
decrease liver enzymes and it
regenerates hepatocytes liver cells so
as you can see it does a lot it can also
help protect the liver against
medication
too much caffeine
alcohol
Tylenol lots of medications and the last
thing is tocatrinols now what is
tocotrinals it's a type of vitamin E
anytime you have scar tissue or fibrosis
vitamin E especially tocatrinos is a
great thing to help break up Scar Tissue
so that's why I included it on the list
also it's a very powerful antioxidant to
protect against free radical damage
inflammation and the things that lead to
fibrosis so the two things that
tocotrinos will do
is decrease inflammation and decrease
the risk of fibrosis and if you're going
to get tocotranol I would make sure you
get it
um as a standalone
complex not added with the tocopherols
because they tend to compete high iron
in your blood can create inflammation
and cirrhosis you also have a situation
where you have blockage in your bile
ducts which can back up into the liver
and create a lot of liver problems
including gallstones and many other
issues as well as your own immune system
where you have liver antibodies that are
attacking your own liver rusting and I
put that video up right here check it
out